in 1995 six teenagers headed to a
distant planet to get the ancient power
they needed to stop ivan ooze from
taking over angel grove now 25 years
later i am beyond honored
to welcome the cast of mighty morphin
power rangers the movie
what would you guys say is the question
that you get asked the most favorite
color do you still keep in contact we
get that one a lot
did anyone date in real life johnny and
i dated for a while but it didn't work
do you think a reunion on screen could
happen someday i'll be honest with you
ashley
johnny have you heard that story no
actually i didn't know
i know we're all sitting here like glued
to this
i know we're loving it
[Music]
i'm steve cardenas i played rocky uh the
red power ranger
i'm karen i played ashley
the yellow power ranger i'm jason david
frank white
i'm gonna play tommy the white ranger
and i'm jason andrew narvey i played
skull who's in charge around here huh
huh
i played amy john johnson oh wait i mean
you're a little different you obviously
don't know who you're dealing with and
i'm ash carlson i'm a producer and host
for et online
and a lifelong power ranger fan i'll be
your moderator this is such an honor
thank you guys so much for coming
what's up how's it going it's been 25
years since the premiere
of this movie what do you guys remember
most it was one of the only daytime
premieres because it was a
it's a kids one all the kids came you
know and the celebrities brought their
kids to
to uh to the premiere so i thought that
was interesting that it was during the
day and not at night
that's interesting you remember that
yeah did you think it was ignited
do you remember that i do i do i
remember um
i was super excited because my my whole
family flew from texas and they were
able to come to the actual premiere
but i just remember being so nervous
because we'd seen it ourselves we'd see
the movie i think one other time at like
a press junket
but to have like your friends and family
sitting in the audience looking at it
yeah they had like a whole big event
after that too
yeah i still have my ticket it's so
funny a
a really close friend of mine sent me a
box of goodies and one of the things
was a ticket to the actual premiere and
somehow
i don't have that it's crazy that's so
cool i just found a vip tag
from the movie you know the press kit
the press kit from
different languages i found all that
stuff and going through my house
remodeling and everything's popping up
yeah oh my god
who's there late to the party but
joining us now we have johnny young bosh
aka
adam park the black ranger
[Music]
how you doing i don't even know if you
guys can hear me is this the yeah we
hear you
oh we're so excited sorry
i was up late rendering files and then i
uh my son woke me up
and needed like a thousand things done
and then uh
i finally got my manager started texting
me well thank you for joining us
what would you guys say is the question
that you get asked the most at
conventions favorite color
keep in contact yeah do you still keep
in contact we get that one a lot
um
my character was written out of the
second movie and that's when i exited
the show
but they did it through a sequence where
i i
fell out of the boxing ring and injured
myself maybe we're not trying hard
enough
people still come up and say like is
your back okay like
i really got hurt you know what i mean
and that's why i left the show and left
a movie
so uh they thought that that's always
pretty funny do you like green or white
that's the most
common question i get and then i say
green they're like sorry i'm a white
ranger fan i'm like that's still me
like you know the names first i do get
that a lot
why why do you have a little loaded
question you know
they do ask us all the time like they
want to know are we friends in real life
do we hang out
i think for them it's like it was such a
moment in their childhood that they
can't imagine that
you know we have to all be friends like
don't ruin that for us
you guys all have to like hang out and
the cool thing is when we're in the same
city or we go to a comic con we totally
do we grab dinner
we you know have a drink we you know
talk about
we talk about everything other than
power rangers we talk about our lives
and
but we just you know we have fun but we
i can say that we honestly all have our
own
you know separate friendships with each
other we used to talk a lot in the text
we might not see each other because
we're all in separate towns you know and
uh
just like now people probably wonder why
all these people aren't on it maybe it's
just time schedules that's what happens
in comic cons too is comic con is almost
not not anymore
but they have like you know 100 of them
a month
so it's really just the time scheduling
when's the last time you guys watch the
movie do you feel like it holds up
i do yeah yeah when we watch it several
times
sometimes you know when we do these
conventions um sometimes
um we'll have like these q a panels that
we'll do with the fans or these like
commentaries that we'll do
where the they'll show the movie and
then we'll kind of like stop and talk
about different scenes from the movie or
have like a big
question and answer panel afterwards so
yeah we've
seen the movie many times since then or
at least i have you know what i i
haven't watched it a lot but it like
steve said we've been able to relive the
movie
relive the series just because we do a
lot of comic cons and comic cons it's
kind of like
every weekend we become power rangers
again and we get to just meet the fans
and now they're adults so it's like i
almost feel like i like it better this
way because i see it in their eyes like
they tell me like how they
they love certain scenes
[Music]
it makes me just remember things i
probably wouldn't remember
doing 25 years ago but it's really
really cool we travel all around the
world meeting them
and we kind of relive it through them oh
my gosh i i remember
um jason david frank when i was a kid
you came to my karate studio in
wilmington delaware
and you asked me what i wanted to be
when i grow up and i still beat myself
up
about this because for some reason i
said a dentist which was a lie and i
just
made it up i said nothing yeah
delaware was that uh david deans or jim
clapp
jim claps jim classy wow
that is crazy
that's crazy i do remember telling each
kid all right everyone say i stand up
and say i can't serve what do you want
to be when you're a kid when you grow up
what do you want to be when you grow up
and i remember
lots of people say ninja or doctor
obviously you're not a dentist it's good
that you hear ashley
makes the super bowl that i taught you
at your karate school but uh just give
them an answer
that's awesome look at
still running the team there baby
so many years after right right a whole
generation
wow it's interesting to watch the
original movie
like you know 25 years out you got to
think about there's not a lot of
superhero
teams that are coming out live action at
that point so it is interesting to see
hollywood and hollywood directors trying
to figure out how to make a team happen
you know i i think we could pride our
crew on
at that point getting it down figuring
out how to get
all these different people to have a
unified message but still maintain their
individuality you work as a team
but everybody has the moment to shine
and our television unit had figured it
out
so it's interesting now to watch an
avengers movie to see they got it down
they got it down
but in power ranger times you know
people don't give power rangers a lot of
credit
because it's a kids movie but they were
really seriously trying to figure out
what it's
like when people come together and
together they're stronger and i think
that's how power rangers even back then
was able to deal with diversity in a way
that
the rest of the superhero movies are
still kind of catching up with
you know yeah and it looks like ivanese
himself is joining us right now paul
freeman
oh my god
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
but back but almost not i was very late
i thought it was tomorrow night
great to see you guys you all look
wonderful looking great dude the beer
looks beautiful
beautiful right the hair has gone a bit
wild but i'm brave enough to go to a
hairdresser yet
me neither paul it's been 25 years since
the release of the mighty morphin power
rangers movie
um have you gone back and watched it at
all like what are your what are your
fondest memories from the set
oh no i haven't watched it um let's
wonder if memories i think just um
you know i had a lot of really good
experiences with these guys
and it was it was all fun i don't
remember
there was a bit of pain when i twisted
an ankle and um
the costume got a bit difficult from
time to time but apart from that it was
all
fun i can't imagine the makeup you would
maybe you were hours in makeup every day
weren't you
yeah yeah i found a page with that with
between alcohol and cigarettes
atta boy nice well do you keep in touch
with these guys
uh i i see jason and paul shire quite
often
at the the meals at the meals
it's the last thing you think about on
those comic cons is the food
no uh comic ones we made up
and i've seen karen a few times and
johnny yeah well
we i saw you too at power more where
were we
at at power morphicon um we have we our
tables were right across from each other
when the fans were coming up yeah
yeah you know we were so excited when
you joined the cast
we were really excited about it yeah
yeah
it was a very strange script when i
first joined he
he was he turned into the ewes all the
time
he was changing sex and becoming animals
and things like
that all of that
went out the way so um when when paul
joined the cast do you guys remember how
you reacted
yeah yeah yeah absolutely we were told
paul freeman was going to be the battery
oh my god you gotta be bella
you know blush do you realize what the
ark is
it's a transmitter it's a radio for
speaking
to god paul's resume is you know longer
than this phone call
um so ecstatic to see him but that's the
thing we knew about paul
when that when they when they hired him
you know is he was an actor's
actor so there's a certain part of us
super excited
and that's also a little bit
intimidating when you get somebody that
that's that good is going to be opposite
you
you know like oh my god i'm a fraud this
guy is real
you're too kind yeah i remember uh
when we did we did our first scene
together when we all met up for the
first time in that construction site
thing
i remember that being nervous about that
you know what i mean because like this
guy here's like this is a real actor and
i'm just some kid from texas who'd never
been in front of a camera before in his
life and a month later
being in you know in this movie and uh
so
i you know but uh paul was actually
really gracious you know with all of us
you know
so um that was that was i was always
appreciative of that so thank you for
that
well you will i have a
and a lot of hard work too i mean we had
fun but it was hard work
and hot wasn't it in that pit i remember
yeah
well i mean it was hard it was like you
know like
november october november which is the
summer in australia so
yeah it was hot so did you guys go
through that phase where you're like
man like i don't want to be tied to
power rangers forever and then when did
you
shift to embracing it and embracing the
fans
after i had left the show um you know i
was running martial arts studios i
didn't
have anything to do with power rangers
anymore you know um
and back then you know there wasn't
social media
you know all the fans were pretty young
and there was no other platform for them
to communicate with us either it wasn't
until
2007 when somebody reached out to me and
said we're going to be putting together
this convention called power morphicon
fans are going to come in from all over
the world that are fans of just power
rangers
and would you come and be a part of it
it's in la so yeah i showed up and did
and when i showed up
i remember there were like 800 people
just standing in the lobby and when i
walked past them all they all started
applauding
and that's when i realized i'm like wow
this is like 15 years later and
these fans like are still stoked on
power rangers it's cool
and then a couple years later jason
frank reached out to me and was like
dude you got to start doing these
conventions because
fans are wanting to meet you and you
know he's like i can help you get
started with all that and next thing you
know we're touring like full time so
um yeah and yeah i have totally embraced
it again how about you karen
you know what same thing we left the
show and we had an opportunity to kind
of live life you know and thankfully
there was no social media or anything
like that to kind of um
pull you back in so like steve said we
started meeting all these fans we
started doing these conventions and it's
like
we have a unique experience of being
able to fall back in love with what you
did
and it was just a beautiful thing to
meet all these people it was really
eye-opening people would come up to me
and and would just say i've never seen
anyone that looked like me
on tv and you you know you were
you were just that person and for me
power rangers never talked about race
but it was a multicultural
show and it's been around for 25 plus
years and
there's always been every different race
every different kind of kid the girl
next door
the smart guy the you know the the sassy
black girl i mean there's
everyone on that show so every kid had
someone they could identify with
and we all were heroes we weren't just
you know
one person got to save the day we all
got to save the day it's a cool thing to
say i was a part of something like that
and people still love it it's still
current it is shocking how much this
this cheesy little show actually had its
heart in the right place
special effects never age well
never age well but again you did have
you had this these multicultural heroes
you know people don't talk about this a
lot but karen
and and walt were really the first
african american live
action superheroes it just didn't exist
you know
so power rangers was looking ahead when
it comes to that when they're
in the demographic of three to six that
is a powerful message that we want right
now
who would have thought little little
cheap show would be on the right side
they answered the question i i enjoyed
doing what i did
i think everyone did but i think also
you know the character tommy had a
little bit more
leeway with producers and executives
that's why i kept going back they we all
had a choice
but i think my biggest thing people used
to come up and say
are you afraid of being stereotyped and
i'd say no and i thought for us it was
like
the movie stood on its own and i was and
i was a karate teacher so it was one of
those challenges to embrace it and go
back to dino thunder when i could not
get an
interview they kept saying oh you're
still part of that show
uh why don't you uh you know
let it go i'm not letting it go because
we're heroes for people and it's not
about being a superhero
it's about listening to people and
really making a difference
and it's the truth let's do it guys
right it's morphing time
you talk about us being part of of your
childhood
look this really was our late
adolescence you know and this is
one of those reasons why of course when
you're an actor you want to
move on to the next thing you don't want
to rest on your laurels like jason frank
was saying you want to be in the next
room and see what the next adventure is
but like it or not this is our family we
grew up together we had a strange moment
where
we were speaking to young kids and well
at least
youth were playing their heroes i was
their anti-hero for crying
i was the what not to do in that cast
but that but we we bought it as a family
because we are part of each other's
history
and the young people that grew up with
this show we grew up with you guys as
well
now the world's looking at us can we
just be hey we're playing actors or do
we have a responsibility to do
better as individuals so that the people
watching can become better individuals
and grow
you know that's kind of how i look at
yeah
i agree have an arc where they become
power rangers at some point
in in the comic book they do okay you
know balkans
always find other ways to become heroes
and again if you f
today that is the thing that would
change they become junior cops
you know they become detectives you know
they do
things that they think will make them um
famous in the eyes of their fellow man
but always for the wrong reasons just
because they want to say
they were right you weren't crazy you
know they always have the wrong reasons
to be heroes
you know and now we have skulls other
half bulk joining us paul schreier
[Music]
hey everybody sorry i'm late i was
making some donuts paul schreier was my
acting coach when i first got on the
show
because i had never done anything before
so paul was always like the one that was
like
off camera telling me to say how to say
stuff and helping me with my lines
in the script so that was awesome
i just said move your neck when you
speak it move
my neck we need ranger power now
i remember that i remember yeah
saying that it's it's been 25 years
since the movie came out
what sticks out to you the most about
that experience just how remarkably
lucky me and my colleagues were
to have been associated with what can
only be described as a worldwide
insane phenomenon it was
like being a member of the beatles i
mean as an actor
so few of us get to have
any success and and and success is not
predicated upon ability it's more of a
role of the dice and chance and
perhaps nepotism but um
for us we were super lucky and i just
feel blessed and i've met some of the
most remarkable
souls and uh and and boy we got a great
group
truly true well spoken paulie i was i
was talking to uh
jason about how you guys were supposed
to have a spin-off at one point
that's true uh we were monkeys and uh
and that was worked out well for us
i never realized until looking back that
you guys really had like a laurel and
hardy thing going on
well marvin could have eaten more you
know but that was one of the spin-off
ideas the young laurel and hardy till
they found out how
roach's grandchildren don't want to give
it up not for us
have you ever wanted to put power
rangers behind you and at what point did
you decide to embrace it and and what do
you love about
being a part of the power rangers today
well we asked for it didn't we
i i always find it strange when uh
performers
um who like myself aspired further
through their formative
years to uh to be professional
performers
but once they achieve that fame they
realize there's a bitter hue
and they suddenly become allergic to
that thing that they questioned for
and and so i i absolutely embrace it
because in fact in life i am an idiot
and so it's not a great leap
i'm gonna be the ego yeah be the swallow
no i'm i'm proud of my work you know i
played a [ __ ]
so um i'm able to go out into the world
and and people
see me buying a loaf of bread and
they're impressed they they realize
i'm functional they're high functioning
they're doing a new movie do you think
if they called you guys will be in it
would you guys all be down do you think
a reunion on screen could happen someday
they probably won't that's true
i was so excited to see jason and amy in
the movie
and then i was so pissed because i was
like they deserved to have
a bigger part in that plot like that was
the letdown for me i think that's what
that last movie kind of missed was the
nostalgia you know
they always ask are we going to come
back are we ever going to be reunited
and i think if they would have just
interjected some of the
that old feeling or some of the the
original cast members or even just i
always call us the mighty morphin 10.
you know pulled people in and actually
put them in the plot you know it might
have been a little bit more
closer to home they fell in love with
power rangers these characters but you
have to really give credit to
all of the actors we brought those
characters to life but it's almost like
they're none of these companies are
nostalgic i don't understand why they
keep missing the mark on that i don't
understand why they keep missing the
mark i mean
when i have all the knowledge that we
have they have all the same feedback
that we have i don't know why they're
not
doing that movie me and amy did two
cameos and they tried cutting it both of
them and the director specifically told
me we are cutting
all ties for power rangers we want to
make this a completely reboot so if we
put
uh jason and amy in the movie it's gonna
bring memories back and the director
came up
at the mood premiere and said i gotta
tell you something
we spent so much money on the movie and
these zords and everything else and we
got more claps for the cheapest scene
that we shot
with you and amy and we did a pickup
shot so we weren't even in the movie
people don't understand the fan base and
i'll be honest with you ashley
they won't until they get desperate and
realize we
all are carrying the brand because we
keep promoting all
the time around the world they have
chances of doing
so many things that they just never did
and now with quarantine they're talking
about a movie
good luck it's gonna be at least three
years before and if you ever see
anything in my
humble honest opinion what a beautiful
thing it would have been though if they
would have been a part of the story
and would have been able to like you
know they weren't playing tommy or
kimberly but playing a character that
could have
helped that team move forward that would
have just it would have
resonated with fans in a whole other way
well many of you guys have returned to
the power rangers i've never
they've asked me i've been asked a
couple of times but it just never worked
out but yeah but yeah the other guys
have
so what is it like when they call you
guys up but like you're just like
yeah i'm down is it weird like what is
it like
it's like an episode i think personally
a 20-minute episode
is just not enough to have that i mean
austin's never returned
he returned back in one episode that's
that's enough you're gonna put any more
people in there your
your fans want more that's what i feel
when i do reunion who who here has been
on the most episodes of power rangers
probably i don't know i'll even in a lot
yeah i got 230 something episodes maybe
i don't know
yeah i'm i'm right at about 400
something with the power rangers hyper
force
stuff how recently have you been on um
in
2012 no no no
no no yeah yeah you're right you're
right
um you're in the yellow ranger yes i was
finally tapped to play an officially
authorized version of the power rangers
in which i was the yellow ranger playing
a different character
than farkas bookmark i was uh
jack dealgood thomas the yellow power
ranger
[Music]
which was cool power range is a very
particular fan base and you know exactly
who
comes to those conventions are hardcore
fans that
have been with us from day one you've
changed my life i was going through a
dark period and you don't know what
you've done to help me and then we have
people that just come and say hey i had
a great life
and we loved you so power rangers did
change lives but we
we don't know until 20 years after it
becomes
a classic i'm doing all the hard work
that maybe the franchise doesn't see
but we are keeping the fans pumped and
going for so many years later people
didn't give that
credit to that teamwork and what we've
done
that's awesome opened up the door and i
was just like oh my gosh like
that's when i felt like that was one of
those moments where you were like okay
we've made it we've been on
entertainment tonight
all of us have been waiting for this all
of our lives now we've always wanted to
do movies the foot in the door so you
know it's like a big step for us you
know so we're excited
very excited we're so proud when we meet
people like you
like you're the demographic you were
five years old when this movie came out
and
i mean literally they walk up to us and
everyone becomes five years old again
and it's just
it's just a great thing it's like i tell
people all the time we're in the good
news business we get to travel the world
meeting people and we all get to become
kids again so
how perfect is that
i have to give a shout out to aisha
campbell though because she knees
ivan ooze in the balls and propels way
comet
what are you doing taking care of
business
[Music]
you know what she was thinking outside
the box you know
something new i always say aisha didn't
get enough credit for that
like she was savage before savage was
even popular
and they took they took away the best
line for her though too and then when
she did that because
when she did that move in in adr later
they said bullseye
and then they took it out of the movie
when i got an adr
they had me say ball's eye taking care
of it like it was like
i said like 30 things and he's right
that would have been
hilarious and now they have something
exclusive content for all people to
i think people would love it now and
understand the fact now
versus being five yeah yeah that's funny
you're hurting here first yo i've got a
bone to pick with you
there was like a lot of like cheesy puns
in this movie like no shortage at all
do you guys remember like which lines
you sticks out the most when tommy steps
up and goes we're the power rangers and
he's all
wait where's my autograph book we're the
power rangers
whoa where's my autograph [ __ ]
is that i just thought that was the best
line ever yeah
that was the one damn paul about paul
freeman
you know who to us was a legend good god
and jason you were saying that you are a
hero
too and you and paul because i think
everyone needs that atomic relief
everybody needs to get away from real
life
and one you know you follow the story
and then bam it throws you off and it
makes you smile
you guys really brought uh you know uh
laughter
and and happiness this story i really
believe that and
heroes come and go but idiots are
forever adam what's wrong
i'm a fraud
yes a frog like the one you kiss
to get a handsome prince i know that i'm
a frog line is obviously iconic but is
there a line that sticks out to you the
most when you think back
about the movie there's so many good
ones i love when aisha's like activating
power beam and then turns on a
flashlight
like yes no i don't remember a line
though other than i'm a frog that's the
only thing i remember
or it's morphin time we did it's morphin
time down on that cliff or whatever and
that
whatever that was that construction site
like i remember it felt like
90 takes of its morphine time how many
times do you think you've said that in
your life
oh gosh no way to count there's no way
to count
time to boogie with the bear my favorite
line was it's time to boogie with the
bear
yes i thought that was pretty
inappropriate
because she was so sassy i loved it if
you go watch the movie everyone's
holding the morpher like this
and i'm holding it like that i never
noticed that
until somebody showed me and i was like
yeah that's so weird and and the only
reason
i know that stuff because fans and
that's the only thing they want to ask
why are you hearing them
this way i'm like i learned through the
fans they point out stuff that you
didn't even realize
it's true we've never noticed they
noticed everything one of my favorites
comes from you when you were talking
about all the things that you missed
while you were trapped in the egg
and you say the pretty much reunion
the brady bunch
[Laughter]
all the reunion that i have missed the
black play
ladies reunion i read that that was an
ad
oh i don't think so i don't think i was
aware what the brady punch meant i had
to have it explained
yeah i think that was in the script
actually yeah it was the other line i
never understood was that i got a
charlie horse
oh yeah charlie horse yeah i've never
i've never heard anybody say charlie
you any idea what it's like to be locked
up in a rotten egg for 6 000 years
it's boring not to mention i've had a
jolly horse since a renaissance you guys
remember like what the biggest change
was from the original
script to the movie walking skull really
were working for the bad guys at first
and then it got into a tug-of-war
because they wanted to do other things
with bulk and skull
so they're like you can't have bad guys
and like
what the hell am i supposed to do with
these guys i know we'll have to be ads
on the show but that's what it was
i know on the original like the original
construction fight we were supposed to
be fighting
rats or big like big rats but they when
they did the test it looked like
um just like like stuff it looked like
funny
zipper yeah and so that's how the
ooze men were born which became a much
better
situation all right pinheads the stealth
eagles about to fly
ditto with a swooping swallow what i
will say is
that the original script had a lot more
i think personal funny moments for each
character
but once the movie started going we lost
a lot of the personal
you know funniness that each ranger had
would have been but
overall it obviously turned out great
but i wish we would have kept some of
that funny stuff because
it really gave a time for each character
to
really shine that's hollywood though you
know it's unfortunate but
i think just do with the timing too you
have a long script and they're like oh
let's just cut that and you're like oh
steve that's happened too on the on the
movie i know there was things that were
cut
from everybody totally maybe
great fight scenes that were cut and
training sequences
like the whole thing with dulcea that
was shot in that japanese palace or
whatever
that all disappeared like i mean there
was all kinds of really
cool i remember shooting stuff where i
was uh
trying to catch flies with chopsticks my
character
got frustrated and then i pulled out my
ranger gun and started shooting them
you know like i was gonna be the quick
draw or something so it all changed yeah
i think the biggest thing that was was
kind of the dividing factor was that
saban they would make the television
show and then 20th century fox came on
and did the movie but 20th century fox
really didn't
know a lot of the intricacies of what
these characters were
in the television show it's like how do
you not know what to do with bulk and
skull they're so
such a pivotal part of this show it was
just two different companies
moving in two different directions uh do
you want us to take another whack at it
how about taking another quack in it
i have a question for many years i
remember you walking on the gravel
the shoes were super hard what did you
feel about those shoes that you were
well dangerous and i know
yeah the funny thing was that the
accident i
had was when i take them off but the
reason for the accident in truth
was they'd made this step out of
polystyrene
and the polystyrene step broke under me
if i'd had my
brothers i should have sued their asses
[Laughter]
i always wondered would not have been
powerful it would have been paul
freeman's mighty morphin power ring
right yeah yeah instead of having to go
to the hospital to see if i broke my
ankle
because the foot just turned over and i
got my makeup on so they couldn't
it took an hour and a half to get it off
so we went to this clinic
and they had to wheel me in in a
wheelchair i still had some of the gear
on
and all this blue face with the bones
and things sticking out of it
like what has this man done to his face
[Laughter]
something weird that's awesome the
clinic we'd gone to
which was just a small clinic in a high
street somewhere in sydney
um didn't have an x-ray machine so they
wheeled me out and
up the high street through all the
shoppers to another clinic i was getting
this oh
[Laughter]
johnny have you heard that story no
actually i did not
i know we're all sitting here like glued
to the
look i know we're loving it we're loving
it if we had social media
paul you would have been everywhere on
social media darcia
that miserable manipulating loathsome
sea devil of a witch if she leads them
to the great power everything will be
ruined
was paul the first like original power
rangers villain then
because a lot of them were like reused
stuff from the show right
oh that's a really good question that
was the first original one then paul
freeman was the one
no the the next one after that let's
talk about this
[Applause]
guess not oh say i was impressed with
steve
i tell people and brag about him because
you know you don't you don't talk about
himself more but he's a black belt and
presenting jitsu which is a really huge
thing
in the in the industry but i remember
the fight scene on it over and over and
over again
and i remember looking at steve going oh
he's got to do all that stuff in those
heaviest boots that he would just do
these flips and kicks
that was pretty impressive thanks man it
it it was a choice that i regretted
because
you know when i looked at him like oh
that looks cool edgy with the comp with
the doc martin combat boots and the
shorts and the
and the plaid shirt you know but when i
didn't realize i'd have to do take after
take after take of flips and kicks with
those things on and
you know did it you know do it with an
extra like you know ten five pounds on
you you know it's like nice
for sure thanks man this this movie had
so many good like suits props
memorabilias did you guys hold on to
anything
and if it's nearby would you be willing
to show us no no don't admit it they
want it back
i know that like david said that
him and a couple of others had gotten
their their ninja costumes because we
shot the ninja stuff
at the end so once they got to go home
you know fly back to america that night
they just took them
but i didn't take anything i regretted
that i didn't take anything
i can't i can't find my original power
ranger boots i have them but the paint's
coming off i saved my boots
and a few absorbent crystals
for a while i don't know you know planet
hollywood in florida
had the black ranger suit from the movie
but it was missing
nice nice i like it i'll take that
i'll take that i hope there's a white
ranger suit out there that's missing a
boot
get this by gabriel junk guard
wow oh you've got it all steve knows
steven
that's awesome paul did you keep
anything
i think i've got excuse me i think i've
got one of the plaster heads i've got a
couple of plaster heads knocking around
somewhere
all right he said i'll buy it off you
i got this dude
you always wanted some of the use yeah
it seemed fun
i think i've got one of those jars
somewhere
i'll buy it off you
the jars of ooze those are so those were
cool i remember that
the slime i thought it was funny you
told the kids to throw it in their
parents faces
take it home in cases if your parents
try to stop you
just throw it in their faces oh did you
keep anything from the movie
do you have anything in your house no
not from the movie i i do have a few
things from the television series in
fact there's a few things that are
within reach now like
plastic food from the juice bar you know
cakes and plastic donuts and weird stuff
that i got off of mark richardson
nice you spar catch you on the flip side
[Music]
why uh why do you guys think that no one
in angel grove was able to identify the
power rangers who all hung out in their
colors they
skydived in their colors they went
rollerblading in their colors
no they could be colorblind [ __ ]
skull
are your typical angel grove citizens i
think you know the answer
that's funny
[Music]
well i have this little section called
fact or fiction facts about this movie
we'll talk about what the actual story
is behind them
so the first one is for jason narvey
here
paul and jason felt underused in the
movie so the producers gave them the
opportunity to be a part of the crew on
the series paul directed a few episodes
while jason was a d
true-ish paulie was was assistant
director for first unit
with a tv show and i was assistant
director for the second unit for the tv
show
directing some some some episodes right
paulie ended up directing a few episodes
um not in australia but he ended up
directing
four episodes i think later down the
line i remember that all the rangers
were were shrunk down in
as into children well paul but jace
i just think that they had so much
talent they had so much organization at
least in my opinion
and that's why i think it was great when
paul directed and when jason was there
because when you're a director it's
you need to lead the actors they would
always come up and say hey
you know give you action verbs or you
know just do it like this or make you
really feel comfortable so i think they
had a lot of talent that they weren't
using
so it wasn't so much like oh we're sorry
here's some episodes
yeah i don't know yeah i don't think it
was we're sorry but yeah no no so what
happened was
um we because the movie ran long so the
network needed
shows and um there was a producer over
there
assisting with 20th century fox in the
movie he was a huge advocate of bulk and
skull from the word go
and so when they needed episodes he
grabbed us and said hey
um i know what you guys have done i know
what your talents are can you help me
get these episodes
shot for the network so that's that's
how it happened
yeah back then it came on daily but even
then they couldn't keep up so they went
back and showed a lot of reruns
so i would imagine like when you're five
years old that must be confusing because
it's like
first you see the one red ranger then
you see a new red ranger so it was
it's very interesting watching the show
back when walter austin and tweet left
because
it's very clear that they were like just
using like stock footage of them
but at the time i didn't realize at all
it was hard filming that
because when i was there i was mostly
putting me in the middle of filming it
and for me being a young
filmmaker young uh actor there was
things i did not understand
because it was just a matter of just
leaving it's a matter of us working
harder me i'm stuck in the middle now we
got to finish these episodes
that process of let's figure out how
we're going to get new people
as an actor it became double work we've
already worked 12 hours a day
but we need a red shirt over shoulder
man we need yellow but we need a black
shirt over that first couple of months
confusing it was really hard for me to
understand how that process worked
they taught me a lot i learned a lot you
know but bringing in these three guys
was that easy
because they didn't have to replace
anyone with different personalities
you know they became their own
personalities i'm sure it's not easy
but i thought all three of them did a
really fantastic job and it was great to
see
the movie because it was a big thing
johnny's blind
i'm a frog i was gonna bring that up
he improvised that that was his line he
made it up he made that line up
adam what's wrong i'm a frog
yes a frog like the one you kiss
to get a handsome prince oh yeah the
frog line
i have the old script somewhere um
but uh we went through a bunch of
changes
you know went through a different dolce
went through so many different things
and uh yeah i just remember a little
overwhelmed a little disappointed
some things being taken away and i
thought you know whatever let me ask the
director
then i was like can i just be bummed out
about having the frog it's not
nearly as cool as these other animals
and uh he was like well let's let's do
like the script says first
and uh we did and then he's like all
right well what's your idea and then
the idea was just to be bummed out i
felt like i got to do
something you know original you know i i
didn't
i never really tried to break free from
the script i always tried to do
what was there um you know
and so it was just that it was just a
chance it was a good ad lib man it was a
good job
i remember that it stuck with everyone
forever
to be in harmony with a sacred animal
spirit
is to have the force of the ninjetti so
gabrielle
fitzpatrick left and then mariska
hargitay
came in but then she got fired and then
gabrielle came back
so i i know this is true because i i saw
marissa talking about it on like a late
night yeah i did too
i was going to be the queen you were the
queen in a power rangers movie that was
me look at that
i think her name was delcia or dulcinea
but i was so excited
because i was going to australia to play
this queen yeah
i was there for
november and then december and then we
were getting close to christmas
and they had me on hold a lot and
finally around december 21st i said hey
guys
this is great but you kept me on hold
too long i gotta go it's christmas
yeah i think that's only fair yeah yeah
so i go home i fly home in december uh
january 3rd i call them i'm like
okay i'm ready no like sweetie you're
good don't worry about it
really yes and they fired me wow you
guys remember like filming with her yeah
we remember like two months a lot of fun
i mean it was it was kind of crazy
because gabrielle had gotten the role
and i just remember that after months
and months of her preparing for this
part
she got sick and then one day mariska
showed up and she was
perfectly sweet but we were in the
middle of filming so it was kind of like
she just got thrown into a movie freight
train
and we filmed with her for about a month
or two
and then we went on a holiday break and
when we came back
gabrielle was back so it was just the
weirdest craziest thing
um but it was nice getting to know her
and working with her and she was suit
like she was so
fun and she was super funny and but yeah
she pretty much got fired because she
wanted to take the holiday and they said
no you can't take a holiday so she
bailed out
yeah it's so crazy it said but we yeah
we were doing that
we should have told her when you're on
power rangers you will work through all
holidays
one day per month he's so
handsome bye thank you yeah i read that
you were
seven hours in the makeup chair and that
you had to swish
like black juice before takes so that
your tongue would stay purple
that's right that was something we
realized after i made up the rest of my
face and suddenly this little little
pink
well a big pink darkness so we had to do
something about
it the seven hours was the first time
when we put all the pieces on that took
seven hours
we got it down to about four hours again
wow
but i was still starting work four hours
before the rest of you guys
god bless you for that well i think one
of the burning questions that i'm sure a
lot of people ask but i'm going to ask
as well
is did anyone date in real life because
the chem was always there
for me johnny and i dated for a while
but it didn't work
johnny and jason
i mean he never told me it's they held
up
paulie and i were married clearly
there's fanfic about all of you yeah
no
you work together with people like 12
hours a day when you're working with
somebody
like you know grueling hours like that
sometimes the last thing you want to do
after and get done with work is hang out
with them you know what i mean
like i never go home and get some sleep
i got to be up at 5am you know i mean i
got no time to date anybody you know
i like to refer to schreier as my first
ex-wife
i heard you're in line to of your ranger
yourself one of these days
nah that's impossible hey anything's
possible
you really think so i know so
well i think we are kind of nearing the
end here is there anything else you guys
uh want to discuss any questions for
each other
um i was just happy of the the cast
joined and
you know everyone stepped into what they
did when i started the show i never knew
what it was all about and i think
everyone that did it was very passionate
about it and we really were
everyone took their martial arts serious
karen looked good johnny you did your
stuff
paul we were excited to have you i don't
know i was just happy to see it come
together and
and uh and here we are so many years
later that we have this platform
we're like in a weird state right now
and the whole world has changed
and uh you know we uh we hope everyone
gets through but
i know this stuff gets me away from
reality for a little bit
and i think that's what you know
everyone's doing out there is to get
away from reality a little bit one thing
i'd like to say is that i thought
um this whole business of doing the
comic-cons which power rangers
introduced me to
uh has has been a sort of a revelation
i've met
such extraordinary wonderful people over
the years i'm very moved by doing them
now
when by the sort of people who turn up
who need us
to be there and you guys who i've worked
with in the comic cons have been
so kind and gentle and sweet with these
with the audience and it's been a it's
been a lesson it's been wonderful thank
you
it's such a blessing i mean i think like
with us it's it was one of those
it was honestly an adventure within an
adventure we got to go to
sydney australia and film this movie and
be a part of this
you know television show and i think all
kids at some point in their life they
pretended to be a superhero and we
actually got to be that i remember tying
a towel around my neck and riding my big
wheel
and we actually got to do a version of
that and
and the fact that you know it's been 25
years and people still watch this movie
and they still love it
and and when we get to meet them it's
such a big part of their life but now
they pass it on to their
kids we feel so blessed to be a part of
that and
to have them in our lives you know power
rangers was this this moment
that we just gave kids a little bit of
escapism but we also kind of showed them
that
anybody can be a hero i think fandom is
beautiful because it gives people
a way to come together in a way that's
active
that creates communities which is
in and of itself heroic finding a place
for yourself
for other people like you for people
that are different than you um
and to find something you guys can
celebrate that is constructive and
loving
it's escapism in difficult times um and
it's kind of um
uh aspiring in regular times
so i kind of hope that's the legacy that
power rangers leaves behind
i just want to add one other thing i
remember which was that you know i used
to have this charity that was set up for
a school in uganda
we passed it on to two of our younger
trustees now but um
the point of this is you were all all of
you individually very supportive
and a lot of the fans were very
supportive over the years and it did the
school in uganda which is
now a new school building a very
successful
still going strong and that's really a
lot to do with power rangers
that's great man oh that's some real
hero stuff yeah
definitely i want to thank you guys all
so much for joining us this has been a
dream come
true i've always wanted to say this it's
morphing time
yeah we had a great time thank you ash
for putting us together we appreciate it
good seeing everybody loved everyone bye
guys thank you bye guys
thank you all so much for tuning in for
more interviews like this stick to et
online i'm ash carlson and i'll see you
guys next time